والله الوضع صب كثير ايش صار ايش صار ايش
الوضع اخ
تفاصيل زي ما انت شايف جاين كل المدارس
وكل الناس مهجره مش قادر تتصلب رصاص بنص
البج مش قادر تصل الناس يعني ايه خصف
مدفع كابت موجوده وكل شي موجود ما حد قدر
يصل في ناس في ناس ما في بلوك تس ما حدش
قدر يسعفهم لا دفاع مدني ولا سحفات اوليه
المداس الحلو الشهداء على الارض يا عم
عمي حرام حلونا يا عمي بلاش كل الدول
العربيه تحنا توقف معنا يا عمض هي الشهداء
اثنين اثنين يا عمي بدوا بجيبوا الشهداء
اثنين اثنين بدوا بجيبوا الشهداء شهداء
على الارض الوضع صعب جدا جدا الوضع صعب
والله الامور صعبه صعبه كثير كثير ه مع
الدوار بيجيبوهم شوي شوي يا عمي هدنه بدنا
تشن شطنا من الشمال طلعنا اجينا على
المناطق الامنه هنا فيش مناطق امنه فش
منطقه امنه صارت بقطاع غزه وضع خطير جدا
على المجتمع الدولي ان يتدخل فورا لان
هناك مشكله خطيره داخل مخيم البريج ضرب
بلا هواده لذلك على كل الضمير الحي على كل
الانسانيه ان تتدخل فورا ورفع الظلم عن
شعبنا
الفلسطيني
ه